now i come to another configuration for
an op-amp and it's partially drawn here
and i'm going to talk about this as i
draw the rest of this circuit in so this
is going to be made from a resistor
configuration that looks like this
we'll have a resistor on the top
and this will be v out
as we did before
and now we have a connection like this
and the connection here
to ground
this terminal is the minus terminal and
this terminal is the positive terminal
now this is upside down from what we've
done done so far but now pay particular
attention here this one has the minus on
top
so now we have r1
and r2
and this is vn
and in particular what we want to do is
find an expression
for
v out
as a function of vn
all right and in this video i'm going to
do it
the hard way
and what the hard way means is we're
going to do all the algebra to do this
and then in a
in the next video i'm going to show you
the easy way the easy way is really fun
to learn and it really helps to see it
the hard way one time just so you
appreciate the easy way
the other thing we get to do in this
video is we'll do the algebra and we'll
see how this gain we take advantage of
this gain to make some assumptions
okay so let's go after this let's
develop an expression for v out in terms
of v in
first let's write some things we know
about v out okay
we know that v out equals
a times
now it's usually
v plus minus v minus this is v plus
this is v minus
usually the expression here is v plus
minus v minus and since v plus is zero
we're just going to put in minus v minus
and this is equivalent to
to saying that
v minus equals
minus
out over a
so what else can we write for this
circuit okay let's uh let's look at
these resistors we have
let's call this plus or minus
vr1
and we'll call this one plus
minus
vr2
so there's a current
flowing here and that we'll call i
so i'm just going to use ohm's law on r1
here and write an expression for i
and i
equals
uh
vr1
over
r1
right another way i can write that
what's this voltage here this is v minus
so i can write this in terms of v minus
and that equals
v n minus v
minus
over r1
all right so that's the current going
through this this guy here
and now i'm going to use something
special i'm going to use something
special that i know about this amplifier
what i know about an op-amp is that this
current here
is equal to zero
there's no current that flows into an
ideal op-amp
so i can take advantage of that what
that means is that i
flows
in r2
so let me write an expression for i
based on what i find over here based on
r2
and i can write i
equals let's do it it's it's vr2
over r2
and i can write vr2 as
v minus
minus v out
over r2
all right so i took advantage of of the
zero current flowing in here to write an
expression for current going all the way
through
all right so now we're going to set
these two equal to each other
now we're going to make these two
equal to each other let me go over here
and do that
vn
minus v minus
over r
1
that equals this term here
which is
v minus
minus v naught
v out rather
over r two
so what i'm going for here is i have how
many variables do we have here we have v
out
we have v n and we have v minus
and what i want is just v out and v in
so i'm going to try to eliminate v minus
and the way i'm going to do that is this
expression over here we're going to take
advantage of this this statement right
here to replace
v minus with v minus v out over a so
i'll do that right here
so let me rewrite this it's going to be
v n
minus
minus v out over a so i get to make this
a plus and this becomes v out
over a
all divided by
r one
and that equals
v minus is minus v out over a
minus v out
over r two
all right let's roll down a little bit
get some room
and we'll keep going
um what am i going to do next next
next i'm going to
multiply both sides by a just to get a
out of the out of the bottom there so
now i get
a times v in
plus v out
over
r1
equals
minus v out
minus
a v out
yeah over r2
there's a lot of algebra here but trust
me it's going to simplify down here in
just a minute
all right so now i'm going to break this
up into separate terms so i can handle
them
separately a
v n
over r one
plus v out over r one
equals
minus v out
over r two
minus
av out
over r2
let's change color so we don't get bored
okay next what i'm going to do is start
to gather the v out terms on one side
and the v in terms on the other side so
that means that this v out term here is
going to go
to the other side
so we got
a vn
over r1
equals
let's do minus
v out over r2
minus
av out over
r2 and this term comes over as
minus
v out over
r1
okay haven't made any sign errors yet
and now let me clear the r1 we'll
multiply both sides by r1
avn
equals
r one over r two
minus
v naught
minus
r one over r two
a v naught
minus v naught
he had the r ones cancel on that last
term
all right
av n
equals
out of here i can factor
this term here
minus r1 over r2 times v naught i can
factor out of that out of here and here
so i can do minus r one
over r two
v naught
times
one
plus
a
minus v naught
so let's take a look at this expression
and
use our judgment to decide what to do
next
now because a is so huge that means that
this first term is going to be
gigantic compared to this v naught term
here
you know v v naught is some value like
five volts or minus five volts or
something like that and a times this is
something like a hundred thousand or two
hundred thousand something like that it
dwarfs it dwarfs this v naught so i'm
going to ignore this for now i'm just
going to cross that out
and we'll move forward without without
that little v naught on the end of the
expression
now this is after we've we've left that
out now we have v in on this side
and i'm going to take a over to the
other side
1 plus a
over a
and this is a point where we get to use
our judgment again again a is a huge
number you know like a million
and so a plus 1 is a million and one
that fraction
is really really close to one
so i'm going to ignore it i'm going to
just say it's one
so we'll send this one to one
and let me roll up a little bit more
just to have a little bit more room
now what we have is what v in
equals minus r1 over r2
times v out and i want the expression
just in terms of v out so i'm going to
spin this around
and we get v out equals minus
r2 over r1
times vn
so this is what our op amp is doing for
us it basically says v out is the ratio
of two resistors times v in
the gain of the overall circuit is
determined by the ratio of those two
resistors and very importantly there's a
minus sign in front of it the minus sign
came all the way through
again let me let me sketch the circuit
real quick
we have the minus sign on top
there's v out
and there was r1 and r2
and the positive input the non-inverting
input was connected to ground
okay
so this pattern with the resistor going
over the top to the minus
this is called a inverting
op amp
and this is a really familiar pattern in
op-amp circuits
you can see these on schematics and
you'll be designing these on your own
so this was quite a bit of algebra it
took to get down to this point and in
the next video i'm going to show you a
really easy way to short-circuit all
this and be able to do this analysis
really quickly and that's called the
virtual ground